in theaters today Mary Queen of Scots
the film has a lot of beautiful period
fashion and only we can reveal it's
behind the scenes costume secrets tell
me about your transformation is film and
the hair and you're on the horses and
you're riding horses in of course it
with a braid how many hours every day
three two full and in real life that's
how long it took to get Elizabeth ready
so kind of looked factory great denim
that's what was used to make searches
blue costumes and when they got mud on
man while the beautiful patterns would
be revealed three layers of fabric went
into making those high collars shaped in
figure eights
and the costumes right he helped me so I
had never worn a car saw or anything
before I had never worn volume skirts at
one time it affected the way you moved
very restrictive and heavy and I felt
claustrophobic and I felt kind of
trapped by you know this image it was
was created for herself it was
poetically resonant Margo had to be
fitted with a prosthetic nose a little
too perfect the 28 year old had nine
wigs and used a bald cap for this
dramatic scene there's no clothes and
Margo had a total of 18 costumes then
searched I had 36 and then there's this
cool factor and I saw you in this one
and I was like is a cropped jacket back
in style like do I want this chapter
there is actually something you'd see on
the runway yeah it's so cool you know so
they're coming back alright call it a
hunch but I think we're gonna see the
film's costumes celebrated throughout
award season Mary Queen of Scots is in
theaters now
you